let's bring in Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire
syndicated columnist and the host of the
Ben Shapiro show Ben good morning to you
morning hey how are you well we saw some
history first time an American president
has ever exchanged words with any leader
from North Korea now they start the
detail light process of dennou keen
North Korea what's your major concern so
a major concern is that if you thought
of the flag that was next to the
American flag as a Nazi flag rather than
North Korean flag then I think everybody
would see the concern this is a slave
state with 25 million prisoners and a
gulag system hundreds of thousands of
people why'd the president's praise for
the dictator of North Korea was
disquieting and here's the reality
diplomacy is a tactic it is not an
outcome and the triumphalism that seems
to be appearing in so many places this
morning where everybody's very excited
the president Trump met with Kim that's
not justified by the outcome yet okay
maybe it will be maybe president Trump
actually got some serious concessions
out of the Kim family but that would be
the first time because virtually every
other president has failed in doing that
and the piece of paper that got signed
yesterday is frankly weak I mean this is
this is not a strong piece of paper if
what Trump says in that interview with
Sean is exactly correct
then we'll all be celebrating but I want
to wait to see if that actually ends up
being correct because there's no history
of this family ever having not lied to
the West well it appears that he wants
to make some changes I mean he fired
three of his dad three of his dad's
hardliners and seems to be taking advice
from other people instead of the people
that ran that awful regime before
clearly this guy also has killed some of
his family members you're right about
the 25 million what does the president
need to do to try to change his mindset
so that he takes all of these people out
of captivity and treats them fairly and
feeds them frankly I think the best
thing the president has done thus far
has been all of the strength leading up
to this particular summit not the actual
summit itself I think that when
President Trump was demonstrating full
scale that he was willing to do whatever
was necessary in order to nuclearized
the peninsula and to ensure that that
North Korea eventually transitions into
a place that is more friendly to human
rights that's a lot better than going
there and patting kim jeong-hoon on the
back III don't understand frankly why we
would have a summit like this from the
president of the United States shaking
hands and giving a thumbs-up to a
dictator
and the president we we are the greatest
country in the history of the world is
the freest country in the history of the
world and putting the flag of the freest
country in the history of the world next
to the flag of an evil dictatorship and
then praising that guy we didn't have to
do this the guy's a tin pot dictator and
treating him as though he's an equal
world leader seems to me
counterproductive but listen I could be
wrong president Trump's proved me wrong
before and I'll be happy to admit that
I'm wrong on your air as soon as all of
the things the president Trump promised
has actually come to pass the tradition
is you go ahead and you have all your
your secretary of state and people the
Undersecretary of State work out this
deal and when you actually show up
you've got a huge book and they open it
up and they sign it it's the last day
this president's doing everything
different from day one I don't think I
have to explain that to his biggest fan
or his biggest critic
so the one thing he's doing different is
we're gonna break the ice of 70 years
we're gonna start with the meeting and
work our way backwards so a lot of this
is faith-based right a lot of this is
faith-based if President Obama had done
this I would be crushing him today in a
president Trump has done this and we're
gonna have to see how it comes out in
the wash because the fact is that
President Trump has not been as weak in
negotiation not nearly as we could
negotiate as President Obama was so the
outcome is going to determine whether
this was a historic turning point or
whether this was a debacle well he was a
stirring his press conference a question
regarding you know what if they don't
really you can't verify they might cheat
stuff like that what are you gonna do
and he said I'm not gonna talk about
that right now
he said I am willing to do anything to
save the lives of 30 million people so I
his heart is in the right place but
you're right the verification thing is
is still a vast gray area that we do not
know how that's gonna work exactly and
my feeling here is that again the
president could have said all of these
things without necessarily going and and
being so kind to - Kim himself but maybe
the president is right you know it's
possible that he always obviously bases
these sorts of negotiations on personal
relationships he feels that he's forged
a good personal relationship with kim
jeong-hoon again I'm deeply skeptical
that kim jeong-hoon and president Trump
are going to be besties and that this is
going to suddenly change the world but
I'm happy to be proved wrong like they
for the thousandth time with President
Trump I'm happy to be proved wrong but I
can't be super optimistic didn't see
what I'm saying when the president is
praising on stage a guy who is as evil
as this guy what do you think
happened to otto warmbier you know the
president said he didn't die in vain
that we wouldn't be at this place if the
world had not seen what happened to Otto
what do you think really happened to him
you've beaten it up and who's beating it
up by the North Korean prison guards in
the North Koreans it's a brutal
dictatorial slaves the other three came
back safely and now his family you know
they're left to wonder why did you do
that to our precious child yeah I mean I
wish I had some sort of vision on why
that happened but if the president
really wants to make sure that our warm
here didn't die in vain that I think
that it is incumbent on him to be as
harsh as humanly possible on the Kim
regime rather than you know hand-holding
and patting his imp adding and giving
the thumbs-up I don't think it runs up
yeah being that there's such a bizarre
country in North Korea the presidents
always said and Lindsey Graham has
backed him up and kind of said it one
way or another it's going to get solved
in his first term so what the other is
going to be the peaceful way or it's
going to be through conflict this
current situation can no longer exist
the status quo doesn't work and they
need to understand that military threat
do you buy that well I think they
certainly need to understand the
military threat which is why I hope that
the president's words in the last 24
hours about ratcheting down military
exercises and and he even made some
comments in his press conference about
pulling troops off the peninsula I think
that's actually the exact opposite of
what we ought to be talking about with
regard to North Koreans the reason
they're coming to the table is because
president Trump is a guy with the fist
inside the velvet glove and if you take
away the fist I think all that's left is
it empty glove I think he said that the
war games were gonna be on hold and the
troops in South Korea will stay for now
but stay tuned all right Ben thank you
very much great hearing from a from LA